hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to outlast 2 now I'm
whispering because we seem to be stuck
in a closet and I don't know exactly
where we're going to end up but we might
still be in though well of all the
places I expected to be this wasn't it
but we've got a message here
Laird there is nothing so wretched among
the afflicted is self-pity and I trust
you not to allow yourself satisfaction
in such a womanly sin if the disciples I
have entrusted you to lead our hungry
and in pain and afraid it's a necessity
of their physical sin and the will of
God
I send you all the food and wine that
God wants you to have and no more I've
had visions of this plague worsening of
all our suffering reaching a point in
which none of us will be able to further
endure so rejoice take comfort that we
will soon reach the center of this
suffering and emerge into paradise
everlasting if you cannot control your
people by their tongue then do so by the
fists of your mount popa loves you God
will deliver you North PS I've included
a satchel of the salted crickets Nick
loved so much please see that he gets
them and knows they're a gift from me Oh
Papa North you're such a big old softy
so kind you're calm
[Music]
well I'm just gonna fine
uh oh I should do this no I can't do
that what you going here no I can't do
that
oh yes I can he won't have any idea
where I've went because I'm such a
sneaky person hello hello well I can't
peek out of here so it's either all or
nothing okay all right then what are you
doing what are you doing and why are you
doing it there's really no need for any
of this you could be a lot less oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god I
forgot right then well I think I have a
funny feeling he knows I'm here
which is good l oh okay I see you back
away I'm gonna go that way okay I'm
gonna get the battery first coupling
okay off we go I don't know why you
can't go hello no not that
oh hi yeah I don't know why I wanted to
see that also this weird arrow floating
in mid-air is cool but apparently so I
think we got to sneak through these
woods while dodging these arrows which
always is a fun excursion but I'm gonna
try not to waste too many batteries soon
because I mean it gave me some whoa what
the [ __ ] was that oh my god oh my god
okay so did
I don't know why but he's being really
really restless today okay I can't hear
any of them and I don't know where they
are which means that I probably got to
sneak around now I don't know exactly
how I got to be in this juncture because
I could have sworn that I came in from
another cabin and all of a sudden he's
being a little bit of why can I hide in
a tree stump I don't think I want to
hide in there they go I'll try to sneak
through this Hey
oh man I'm just - oh hi oh hi why are
you in the woods why are you in the
woods oh boy
okay all right oh okay we're fine fine
oh no oh wait I don't need light here
it's frickin Oh frickin bright as [ __ ]
okay but there's some oh I oh that's the
big guy oh that is most definitely the
big guy and he is right there he has not
moved he's not moved to muscle so I
gotta find a way to sneak snack around
him alrighty then yeah I think I can go
through the right side because he seems
to be delegated over there now I'm gonna
go over here with us dead bodies and
flies great okay he's over there I think
I see a light in the distance that's
either him oh I forgot that there might
be someone in front of me over here oh
he's coming this way
okay I see a big guy I see a big guy
okay just don't come this way and we're
gonna have a good old time we're gonna
have a great time mmm also it's been
brought to my attention by you guys that
I need to check more of my recordings I
kind of learned that after the last one
that I found in the dream world was
garbled and backwards and there might be
a hidden message in all those things but
I don't have time to think about that
right
okay yeah okay we're fine
cool boy oh boy can i lock that yes I
can't okay no okay don't do that yeah do
this that's the smart maneuver Subban
that guy's cool there's two doors you
thought there would have been two doors
okay so I need why what [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] what you do that that was
completely unnecessary I was taking my
time
Oh shitty dicks Oh Oh boom now this
didn't go sit where I can't go anywhere
oh [ __ ] this is bad yeah oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god who
creepy crawly creepy crawly look here we
go I don't know where I'm going
oh I'm going over this way apparently
whoa hey don't do that don't do that
yeah freaking son of a [ __ ] over there
okay
okay we seem to be fine
I don't even know why we went in that
house if it was just going to be filled
with death but okay just a trap two
doors didn't do [ __ ] up against Nick
yeah he's too strong all this seems safe
okay I'm gonna trust my life to this
precarious bird oh that's the opposite
of good is there a message on that arrow
all right I'm gonna keep trucking along
hopefully no cacti are gonna get in my
way
oh god damn you fine don't be like that
you sack of [ __ ] huh see how good a shot
you are when I'm [ __ ] it all miss me
by eyes there's a cactus bug down ahaha
okay run run run run run too hard
haha missed me run run run run dogs
No I'm gonna go with no rule boy oh hi
you're just waiting arunya
you're just waitin so grumpy
it's the world for making me this
hideous Lydia give me you carry on I'm
gonna go up here
it seems like a good place to go again
it's telling me I need to peek from a
ledge but I don't know all righty then
he's gonna start a forest fire this
range he'll badoo badoo badoo badoo and
out nice guys full of arrows alrighty
then Shepherd even even even even every
Josh Oh [ __ ] ow God
what he got smart and started aiming for
my legs well I got a hippity hop over
those boughs I find then no you don't
reload [ __ ] huh
whoop point shoot Badou blip blop sleep
sport
it hurt but I'm alright alright I can
pick it up for me
suppose these guys didn't seem to pick
it up very good alright but i can take
this and this is gonna help me get along
cuz apparently he's getting more
accurate he's going for the 200 your
crucifix wasn't
Oh too bad your muscles are all melting
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] hell whoa whoa
the [ __ ] is in here there's something in
here how what the [ __ ] is that I thought
there was something in there it seemed
like there was gonna be a secret in
there and I went for it being all stupid
like not trusting what I was doing I
love her at least we didn't lose any
progress here it seems all right
Oh cacti delicious I'm full
all right and I don't know what it was
even Jesus this poor son of a [ __ ] no
it's okay we have you well that's not a
good thing you're just shooting arrows
at me why should I be comforted by that
dude
do I have any objection to this can I
actually say no to this who is this kind
of a kind of expected of me thinking no
no this ain't ended this tainted sainted
taint sainted taint Sanford yeah please
don't you take care of yourself now you
take care of yourself Prabir
again under the ground dad all right Oh
can I do something now yep still in pain
Oh hand still hurts laughing my meat
against that wood doesn't do much come
on don't do a very good job at this [ __ ]
really that's it that's all it takes we
have a need to put a guard on me or
something at this point I'm rooting for
them because this isn't exactly fair all
right fine then we'll play it that way
did I document my own whoo hey come on
now don't be like that don't be like
that
hey hey don't do that I don't this is my
brother broken and killed by the tire
layer heads bounding / why I don't know
what that said I didn't have time to
read it this guy's slapping his way
towards me oh he's so slappy why Oh
what do they all gotta be so gross and
disgusting this laughing okay so I wish
I had time to pause and rest but it
don't so I'm gonna review my footage
later Oh everywhere oh they're
everywhere
well there's no getting away from these
guys I can't make you clean your - dirty
Bilski right fine then where am I now
where did I run off to oh boy oh boy oh
here we go
I still hear him slapping behind me so I
can only assume the crawling through the
same gap that I came through unless
their meat is just gonna fall off their
bones their leash it seems like I got
some respite alright
ooh hello resource greatly oh you scald
you afflicted with boils and sores all
you who sex cracks and weeps your
Baptist comes to astride a donkey in the
shape of a man that Baptist proportion
is a child and all but the tools of a
man and therefore best beloved of the
prophets Sullivan north and north said
unto lad what desire is now in your
wretchedness I desire to behold the
things which the new zekiel saw and
North said J thine mind is too tight and
are before the girth of the Lord's
message and would split in its
penetration thou shalt knowest only your
own salvation and lad said yea I believe
all the words of my father and North
cries hosanna in the highest as they
love me thou art blessed and you shall
behold the things which thou has desired
and Lance spoke I see the heavens open I
see fly smoke in the sky
a cloud of insects bearing down a man
full grown yet virginal most beautiful
and fair above even the beauty of women
and I look to new I beheld the Redeemer
of the scald of who Ezekiel had spoken
it and thus called Messiah shall save
this is my flesh eat of it and be healed
whoever eats of my flesh of have eternal
life and they shall proclaim the glory a
lad who lead them to salvation okay so
this is why Laird was all kinds of
obsessed with making sure that he
fulfilled the prophecy but hey I think
Laird said I was beautiful on my way to
the mine yeah definitely okay so what
have I got here
I want to review this see gospel of the
saint okay ah clean text huh okay what
do we got here of this
huh okay oh I missed some okay Wow I did
it
crazy what is this I don't even know
what I was looking at some kind of
deformed toddler deformed toddler oh
okay yeah sure all right yeah that's
what it was
sickness here god bless at least the
people were rotting even before they
were murdered yeah yeah I can't make
sense of any of these Gerald ones but oh
the locust was i recording that I don't
know how many of them got in my mouth oh
this kid would stop itching
trying to lift me up gross
man this poor guys this is beaten to
[ __ ] every single place he goes meat
hung to cure hooks through their
Achilles tendons Wow aren't you
scientific oh you know your [ __ ] don't
you okay they always hurt women to
punish men it's sick it's kelp yeah I
might agree on that one Oh chapel the
chapel is supposed to be sanctuary yeah
I think I cried out for that before
didn't quite work out that way but I
seem to have missed some stuff going to
heaven
before they kill the children yeah
there's no good I'd have loved me what
am i doing I don't know what you're
doing what are you talking about you
should have loved me what does that even
mean uh I guess this is where the magic
happens this is the magic Oh tears for
an audience to watch oh I only saw her
afterwards oh I couldn't if you couldn't
have one helped talk to her I guess I
didn't try so maybe that's my fault
so--yes found him by Sullivan off the
modern Ezekiel yeah sure
their knives sharp for the enemy yeah
gross okay ciao I could see the trap
lafarge discovered I'm feeling mighty
that the sound of scissors yeah maybe so
weird going back into what I said she
did it to herself he said he was
protecting you huh
are you talking about who are you
talking about Oh No music of birds is
proof God exists loves us oh oh so sad
don't remind me of the dead birds Oh
weird okay so I gotta go back so this is
all in the beginning so I'm gonna just
I'm gonna make sure that I review any
footage that I see thus far and make
sure that I try to get everything that
possible because I started missing stuff
when I was fiddling with the cameras but
I think now I'm getting more and more of
everything well there's no need for that
there's no need for any of that you can
just stop that's always an option you
can just stop oh hello what am I looking
at oh hi oh hi why
oh you seem alive okay
maybe not oh boy alrighty then I'm gonna
review this one pull just there's a
lesson to what I'm doing here
she hanged yourself before I could stop
her what or she did it
no wait not her wait yeah who you
talking about [ __ ] yeah you're talking
about Jessica aren't you you are this
guy's brain is getting scrambled up I
mean he is in unimaginable pain which
just goes to show that maybe he's uh not
doing too well these days so honestly
who knows boy is not going well at least
he can get through this nightmare in one
piece
ha ha that's a laugh he's not gonna get
through this in one piece at all he even
gets to this through this through this
in the beginning Jesus okay
so this is a convenient place barely
okay glad I held onto my camera with
that one No
what do we got here sorry I had to take
the rope from off this pulley because I
needed to climb to heaven if that
bloated Ezekiel won't give you no more
rope you can cut me down and take it
back cuz i SPECT I'll be done with it
okay are you is this a guy that was just
out there McMahon all these events are
transpiring immediately now like
immediately now they're happening right
now that letter that I read in the
church got a reply that I read down here
so it can't have been that far behind
yeah you can you big baby
I needed a rope and now I know where I
need that rope okay I've fallen off
mountains before you think that's gonna
stop me oh there's a gap to go above it
yeah sure can take the actual door I
gotta go
you don't have to actually tell anybody
that I'm here that's not okay
god damn it these spoil sports all right
fine what are you gonna do about it oh
geez no thank you
I've already been on the cross I don't
need to be there again oh boy oh boy
jumped up dump dump dump here we go here
we go here we go round and round the
rosy rose here we go what were you oh
this place is occupied anything in there
no okay
oh hi okay why then I guess we're fine
supposedly yeah all right
oh oh oh good throw anything
the better option I find then well that
happened okay so where's the body
where'd the body go somewhere over here
oh thanks yeah thanks oh hi no no no no
no no no you don't know I'm here do you
you're just a fairy oh god oh god oh god
[Music]
how's a close one I could even see that
flying towards me whoa hey hey hey hey
hey no need for that she shouldn't have
told on me oh boy he's real close okay
yeah you keep yelling at your own guys
oh he doesn't know I'm here I think I
can go around this way get out of here
point me in the right direction please
thank you we're gonna go we're gonna go
we're gonna go we're gonna go we're
gonna go we're gonna go we're gonna go
this is not the correct way well we're
gonna go oh no put that no but yes that
one okay good
why'd they do that why'd they do that
why why did they do that oh hi how are
you oh you don't look so good ah you all
right there buddy no you okay
nah okay nah yeah you're not so good
just let me review this one oh yeah
my dad died within a month my mom okay
he was perfectly healthy until she was
gone
I see what that has to do with my six
zooming action over there so maybe you
could pay more attention to what's
actually going on in front of your face
she's um
fine fine men if you want to be a big
dumb goofy do about it okay how do i
where am i what am i doing oh okay all
right this is a thing holy [ __ ] no they
make it
we know yeah you don't know where you
are do you I mean then again I don't
know where he is but he doesn't know
where he is because his mind is breaking
due to some unseen influence in this
town hi how you doing over there so if
this is the influence that it's having
on this guy who has only been here just
a little bit I mean even though he has
demons of course you are
oh no oh no oh no I don't like the fake
footprints [ __ ] I mean it's a fake
that grabby hands man is all over the
place I just don't like it
oh good of course that's a good affect
okay hop this yeah we'll get here T
somes now this area reminds me of the
original outlast when you were wandering
the courtyards and you were trying to
find your way through all the fence
Terry's because for some reason that was
a very fenced asylum and they did not
want nobody going nowhere
oh boy but this reminds me of that but
but that's the interesting thing I have
not drawn too many conclusions or or
like correlations between this and the
original out lass and I'm actually kind
of happy for that because this makes I
mean with the same elements of the
camcorder and whatnot but it makes the
story kind of this unique experience
that like it's new and interesting and I
actually like that and I haven't had a
chance sex you talk about the game from
a game standpoint for a while now but
you
okay oh wow okay oh do I just this is
just okay this is the way it is now
Oh God all right then
cool yeah ah dude all right okay yeah
right
[ __ ] just what what is that supposed
to be okay so the come from top and
below but I didn't see this guy I was
looking the other way
oh boy okay you gonna be up there now oh
it's not - it's one okay all right
you'd be down here could be down here no
yes oh I didn't know he was gonna be
running I didn't know it was gonna be a
running kind of thing I was up I wasn't
prepared for that at all no no no I was
not it's not okay you're down there okay
and then you're gonna be up here and now
I'm gonna run back down not be a big
dumb idiot right
all righty then
um am i okay Jesus I bet they didn't
expect anybody to die they're twice like
an idiot
oh okay I just got the weirdest
flashback to uh to became very few of
you are gonna actually remember but some
of you is the first experience of my
channel I just got a flashback to
slender elementary do you guys remember
that one yeah yeah not particularly well
made but it was when those slenderman's
shadow series were being made and it's
got it is it caught wind of it somehow
super weird but I love it oh man hope
you guys aren't drowning and nostalgia
at this point well is he done flocked
okay where do I go oh oh no I just went
through there it can't it doesn't open
so where do I go Oh what the [ __ ] is
happening oh this one okay that would
have been those little difficult to
point out okay hi hello hello hello
oh man that hallway looks bad this
hallway looks I mean also bad because it
goes nowhere but okay I'll take this
option with a dark scary hallway in the
[Music]
okay alright I read the wrong way good
God don't do that to me dick I'm not
that bad at games Oh Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday okay brag I
said how do you make a half oh it's the
cursive F
oh that's stupid you're stupid I think
they got tons of green beans all right I
don't know if I want to go that way I
don't know if I want to go this way all
right I guess you're removing all choice
for me but I'm making my way further and
further through the school I do notice
that I'm in the exact same school I
start out in every single time and I'm
just making my way through the entire
environment I'm not necessarily making
any like new revelations here it's all
the same place don't let me go I think
that's the same one that was there
before I didn't quite get that okay can
you Jessica Oh Jess there's no what I
didn't get time for some reason I didn't
have my camera yeah can you hear me oh
oh I don't like that hi oh hi oh can you
stop that please oh please stop tickling
my ear with your horror sounds oh here
we go oh well later flight cheapy this
night and check on me
Ling rice and sprite I need not fear
that one year so art my Savior behind
and here
Oh God the Sun look down pun little one
light of light keep me this night and
shed on me my presents bright this way
Blake Jess are you there okay okay all
right
not cool but okay
hello oh okay oh oh oh ah good how did I
make it here from wherever the hell I
was oh my god how is this happening like
either all of this is an illusion like
in the evil within or I am in some sort
of a fugue state that just so happens to
coincident with the actual world and yes
coincident is not a real world than
anything it's not it's not real work and
add capacity geum's
but I've I made it to the goddamn minds
yet I think I've gotten sidetracked
enough Oh what is that really not so
easy when you're flipping in out of this
dimension ha buddy
stop doing that god damn it you'd think
that they would just let the camera be
glued to your face I mean why would you
have the option of putting it down if
you're only supposed to go through the
game lift it up at least it seems like
it's that way
all right here we go hello oh hi
uh I'm not putting a [ __ ] til that
water lake is wrong okay whatever you
say you know I'm now gonna put my toes
in that water
oh that looks wrong oh that looks very
wrong what am I looking at what am I
looking at the water mmm
don't look good got it nailed it nabbed
it let's do this the lake smelled like
chemicals and dead things Oh dead things
like me like Jessica I guess no okay
yeah I can't believe I missed that
dammit I wanted to get that poop cannon
ball cannon cannon ball I'm gonna swim
for it apparently this is working
Hey
I can't put my camera up anymore oh
there we go
apparently why am I just here by okay
hello oh [ __ ] that was grabby hands and
that was the voice on the phone oh okay
maybe they're one in the same you know
what I'm saying yeah why's that cause
grabby hands
it's just went underneath but that guy
looked like he might have been a priest
which makes me think that something
happened with those priests at the
school that he grew up in and I don't
want to go the cliche route but it seems
to me that maybe just maybe something
bad happened you know what I mean
I don't I don't want to be that guy but
yeah it seems to be the way that this is
leaning towards and that caused Jessica
to kill herself I guess it's horrible
all right but I gotta find a way in the
air which I just did I think
whoa okay all right then no oh come on
money in me and oh wait there's a place
oh there's a pit underground which means
that there's way to crawl and right here
nope this is alive this is not the right
way but I'm on the right track so there
must be a way in from under here maybe
no he's gotta be a win I know that for a
fact
oh here we go hello I'm gonna call my
way up never mind no I'm not okay that
was just a joke I was joking about that
it's not you're not gonna do that okay I
can't find a way in I wish I could but I
can't cuz that window doesn't open in
none of these places seem to lead to
where I need to go and that's not open
up there so I guess I'm on my own then
so what do I need to do to be able to
get through this Lake okay thanks for
stumbling yeah there's gotta be like
something here that's gonna help me
I don't know how they're fishing with
mr. grabby hands in there but that again
that again is in my mind right and
there's some screaming going on in the
distance I don't know what that's all
about but maybe I can get in here no but
maybe these houses are connected maybe
I'd be able to get in that way no all
blocks these guys have some sturdy locks
holy Nick and Laird we're still alive
then maybe I'd be able to get them bash
it open but unfortunately answer that
seems to be No
all right nothing yet oh but I made it
behind here okay so this is where I
needed to go and now I need to get
across the lake and so hopefully
something up here is gonna help me
someone had a luxury mansion up hello
okay whatever you say well not on that
edge yeah oh I don't know who's doing
all this deck building here because
there are a lot whoa what am I looking
at what what I don't see what you're
talking about
well that's Oh Power Station don't look
at god damn it don't do that
god damn it it's so easy to hit the
goddamn button [ __ ] sorry about that
it's so annoying uh and Boop what do we
gotta say about that one hello tower a
radio tower or microwave really okay
civilization maybe yeah that is weird
because I was dumb enough to think I
might not die wait what for a second I
was dumb enough to think I might not die
wait what
but that's not the statement that you
make after you see civilization huh wait
what and also that is a stone's throw
away from all of this insanity right
here and there seems to be like one of
those smokestacks like there's obviously
a power substation and there's obviously
a hell of a lot of contracting going on
around here
cuz they need food I mean they need some
medicine for papanov who's not
practicing what he preaches you know
that's a good place to jump off not
gonna do it though Jesus it looks like
the moment from all my bones from until
dawn right at the beginning of the game
when they fall into that pit the sisters
do right at the beginning owner of it
yeah yeah what the [ __ ] are you talking
about that over there okay
not yet big buddy not yeah we got a lot
more to explore over here don't lose
your mind yet not yet okay here we go
nailed it slightly broken bones but what
else is new
cuz I've been impaled on like a fence
I've been impaled on more than just a
fence I've had nails driven through me
I've fallen down so many times I
survived a helicopter crash I am a
broken man where I should be anyway but
apparently I'm made of steel and this is
impossible to cross over see he's a cold
I should know about because you all ran
away real quick and I don't like being
left in the lurch with the red candles
the red candles kind of signified The
Heretic territory hello hello okay hello
yes so this must have been a heretic
place it kind of just all blends
together huh
Marc Erin if you find this head straight
back to temple gate and tell Papa not
there is a horror and torment here that
tests even my faith in God
men alone cannot face it the enemy waits
in the darkness here god save my soul
and yours so why am i going deeper into
this oh my god I just shouldn't have
lost my wife should have found these
goddamn heretics long ago alrighty then
so there must have been some way to get
into that house but I just didn't see it
hello oh good no bud I'm gonna be no bow
to fire here no luck no boat is that a
dead body I bet it is
freak all y'all alright carrying on oh
why why who did that
[Music]
why who did that and why ok right then
ok I'll take that thank you Oh what am i
recording Oh what am i recording what
are we looking at I never know what
you're looking at
alrighty then seasons help help help
wasn't coming help where in the world
did you read help I have no idea what
he's talking about I have no idea
Chism's ok but I better carry on the way
that this these guys went when they were
running into the darkness because it's
gotta be something here rights oh good
oh good dead end where did they go then
Reverend North I will not be returning
from a hunting trip for several weeks
and so hope all reaches you with this
letter more swiftly checking the traps
on the far side of the mountain
approximately five miles beyond the
mines
I spotted metal towers along the tallest
trees they appeared to be camouflaged
but poorly by oddly symmetrical leaves I
attempted to hike down to the base of
the towers thinking I could find out
what they were for
or at least who built them but I don't
expect I got much more than a mile in
their direction before I was overcome
with waking dreams as of a power I had
never experienced before I thought
things that I cannot describe there were
flames and insects and what may have
been mouths and what may have been sex
organs I must have walked from inside my
dream state because I found myself on
waking a great distance away and have
not been able to trace my steps back to
those humming towers there were other
less dignified responses in my psychic
which I cannot put down on paper for
embarrassment maybe I will be able to
tell you in private upon my return to
temple gate so what that means is that's
not just civilization those are towers
that are pumping out some sort of
psychological signal that is messing
with the population here which means
that maybe all of this that getting
across where you talk about what raft I
don't see a raft
what do you keep saying things that I
don't see but either way that means that
those towers over there might be pumping
out a signal or maybe not even those
towers that could just be a power
substation that that powers them and the
other ones that I saw right there those
might be the one that are broadcasting
something
so I don't know what it all means but it
looks like I've got the means of
transportation to get all across this
lake but that's gonna have to wait until
the next episode because I'm all out of
time so thank you everybody so much for
watching and pay attention to the weird
humming sounds in the air because that
may mean something so thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]